vom großen kino jetzt zum großen theater
susanne marie wrage kommt gerade von der
ersten hauptprobe schweizer schönheit
wie ließ durchmischt das ist sehr
aufregend und da was nicht gut spielen
sie die nymphomanin die nachbarin
den hat man ganz genau das heißt betrügt
sie ihr mann ihr mann mit dem vornamen
ich verrate nicht alles nachträglich
nichts war okay ist es schulen teil
es ist ja ein bisschen was schon
sozusagen vorausgegangen es geht um die
ganz sympathische hölle die wir alle
kennen des reihenhauses
eine situation die ihm vertraut ist
sondern eine die ich schaue wie der
teufel das weihwasser also die
vielleicht von kindheit her kenne wald
aufgewachsen ist woher ich komme aus dem
schwarzwald aus einer sehr katholischen
und sehr kleinbürgerlichen gegend wo
eben auch verrückte menschen sehr
schnell ausgegrenzt wurden oder fremde
und insofern aber auch eben man sehr
dicht an dicht war und ich glaube ich so
mein ganzes erwachsenenleben vermieden
habe in so eine situation nicht
zurückzubegeben wartet dann auch der
berufene flucht ja ich denke schon das
thema bei unserer sendung heute ist ja
liebe kommt die liebe gut weg indem in
dem stück schweizer schönheit nee gar
nicht glaubt glaubt man da noch an die
liebe in dem stück nein ich glaube man
man weint ihr hinterher der gewesen
liebe und sieht die perspektive nicht
einer kommenden sein denn glauben sie
persönlich gekommen
müssen sie im stück beim küssen
ja ja wir wenigstens das team hat mich
gelehrt hat ja und das team hat gesagt
der film ist ja dass gewisse ich kenne
niemanden mehr der noch einem filmkuss
praktiziert also man ist doch manchmal
künftig mehr oder weniger sind auch
keine filmkuss wir sind wir haben da
keine nahaufnahmen das sind auch eher so
so die die beruhigende küsschen so nach
dem motto kommen seiner braven das
beruhigende küs leider leider keine
keine leidenschaftlichen also würden sie
das gerne auch so gut müssen sie einen
partner kennen und leidenschaftlichen
kuss zu spielen gar nicht haben sie es
gehört dass woody allen so macht die
leute auch für bettszenen lernt sich
zwei minuten vorher keine sackgasse
dexter 66 und los geht's ich habe auch
schon sehr viele filme gedreht wo wir
immer mit den szenen angefangen haben
bevor man das team überhaupt kannte das
man eigentlich intimstes 10
also das heißt sie wir können uns jetzt
küssen wirklich und würden wäre es im
bus küsschen oder moderne sich nicht
gleich ist man noch nicht vorüber wir
kennen sie auch schon sieben minuten und
schon vor einiger zeit mal in stuttgart
beginnt aber das war nur in die rein
beruflichen aus der ferne oder damit
aber schön dass wir uns jetzt wieder
getroffen
ja da kann man ja nicht besser entdecken
zu dieser zeit habe gar nicht